Jonathan takes eighteen  wide open three-pointer and pedicumpo  another offensive rebound and hammered  once again  he's doing an outstanding job of  attacking the offensive boys  New York Phoenix you're doing the right  thing a poor job of rebounding but tying  him up and forcing them to make free  throws but he's doing a great job you  don't get the basketball well he a  problem that playing small and not  surrounding you with bodies offensive  rebound  the only thing I would say about him as  in comparison to Lopez Lopez keeps it up  high and finishes High Giannis drops  that ball down which allows teams  to try to foul and gives them time to  foul versus getting it off quickly we'll  see him bent over and he plays so hard  you see the big third quarter and I've  seen the last 25 years most points in a  quarter in the finals game  now belongs to giannisote with 20 points  here in the third but right now